[Music]
my whole life i've had this narrative
for my mother
that my father who had you know he
passed away my husband was at work and
he got a call from a stranger and it
turns out he is claiming to be my father
whoa
[Music]
what up what up if your milkshake brings
all the boys to the yard i'm glad you're
with us and if it doesn't i'm glad
you're with us too
right here on the dr john dolone show we
talk about mental health relationships
schools education anything you want to
talk about
we are here for you so glad you're with
us
ben is running the board cause james
isn't here today so it looks like we're
gonna have a party that's gonna be good
no probably not really it's gonna be the
same as always it's cool but we'll
pretend let's go out to claire in
cincinnati what's up claire how are we
doing
doing good how are you we are having a
blast what's up
so dr john i have a situation so i have
a couple questions for you anytime
somebody starts a sentence with
so
then i always have to hang on to the
desk a little bit all right so what's
going on
so alright again um
my whole life i've had this narrative
for my mother
that my father um
is her ex-husband
who has you know he passed away um she
told me some
he saw great things about him too that
he was workaholic he was abusive so that
was kind of the narrative that i had
um and then flash forward to
20 something years later
my husband was at work and he got a call
from a stranger
he was asking questions about my father
and it turns out he is claiming to be my
father
um
yeah
he offered like a dna test and so i i'm
taking it pretty pretty seriously yeah
so he he offered to take a dna test or
he offered to show i mean
how do you know this isn't just some
creep of the week
person
i think
because of how my mother is
it would it would make sense
have you talked to your mom about this
no
it's very hard to approach her with
things why
um
i'm a pretty sensitive person i don't
like confrontation
and she is
narcissist is a very strong word but
there are a lot of tendencies that i've
seen
so it's kind of a bullying like no
responsibilities ever taken it's
switched back on me so my fear is if i
go to her with this
i'm just going to be blamed somehow
and my trust has already been pretty
violated so i don't really want that on
top of it
so
here
tell me if i'm off okay
it feels like somebody came out of the
blue
and told you some things is he giving
you some like convincing this is or that
or is he just
telling you hey i'm willing to take a
dna test i'm pretty sure i'm your dad i
look like you like we have same color
hair i mean what's he telling you to
convince you
so i haven't actually spoken to him yet
he called
this is kind of a red flag to me he did
he called my husband
not me
so i haven't actually spoken to him yet
okay so
here's what
man
here's what i wanted you to be careful
of
your mom told you your dad passed away
when you were young is that right
okay
there's a part of you
that really hopes that's not true
and what kind of story would it be if
all along your dad was alive and you
found him and
sounds like you've had some challenges
with your mom over the years some heavy
stuff some hard stuff
and to the point that you don't even
want to ask her is there a chance that
her story so
the idea
this
person could come and really fill a hole
that you have a mom and dad size hole
that the the appeal of that story just
from me as a listener who just met you
like a minute and a half ago dude i want
that to be the case in your life
and i want him to come out and be like
she told me you had passed away and here
i am and all the story and like i want
that to be the case
we are way
way far away from that
right now you've got some dude who
reached out to your husband
maybe from your mom's past and is
throwing a story out
so one of two things happens if i'm you
number one i'm going directly to my mom
and saying i am scheduling a dna test
with a man who claims to be my father
is this possible before i go through
this not hey what do you think but i'm a
grown woman who can do whatever i want
to and i'm about to do this
do you have anything you want to tell me
that's probably the track i would take
and i know you don't like
confrontationalists this confrontation
has found you not the other way around
okay either you are faced with a
26 27 year old lie
and you've been robbed of of your entire
life of having your father in there in
your life
or
you have a psychotic crazy person trying
to get into your life trying to weasel
their way yeah you hear what i'm saying
and it feels like the story here in your
soul has spun up much faster than the
data that you're working with
the other side is have you i mean this
guy want to meet you does he want to
talk to you
he does um
so when he spoke to my husband
he was kind of
my husband was saying you know we're
going to need to sit on this for a
little bit contact will not be
direct um
so yeah he knows like it'll take a
couple
couple months here to like reach out or
initiate anything and so what what is
going to happen in that couple of months
like what are you gonna just sit and
think on besides just making yourself
crazy
well i'm also pregnant and i'll be
giving birth here soon so that was kind
of
my main priority and i
think i just want to protect the family
that i have already i don't really want
to
introduce this new guy if he's not worth
my time or if he is crazy because that
was something i thought about too you
know like this random guy like now i'm
having a child and you want to be in my
life it just
it did feel a little bit weird
the whole thing feels weird
what i don't want you to do is allow the
weird to come to you i want you to meet
the weird head-on
and you sounds like you have a great
husband with you
maybe you offer um i don't know if they
would do this in your area i know some
places would
that you reach out to the non-emergency
police department in your area or the
fire department in your area and say a
man has come out claiming to be my
father and i want to do dna tests would
it be possible for us to do it there
where there is safety
and um or possibly at a local hospital
um or i just had some blood work done a
follow-up just
doing a bunch of blood work for my
doctor and i went to a place and they
said that they do paternity tests and
all kinds of things there all of the
time and they can schedule them
um in staggered play we were i got to
talking with the phlebotomist and it was
she was fascinating man she sees some
stuff
but she's seen um paternity tests like
people get fistfights there she's had
people come in and do paternity tests
and then leave and then the next person
comes in and and then she calls both of
them back or emails both of them back
with this you know you are not the
father you are that kind of thing
i think you can set that up
and or you can go to the local
phlebotomist which is just like one of
those you know any lab test now kind of
places and they're on street corners
everywhere you could go in actually do
your test and then have your husband
contact this person and say
i've done she's done her part of the
test you need to go to this place and
have it done and then the test results
will be sent to her
you can do that and then you never have
to talk to him see him and if this
person's interested in being in your
life they can go get the test done
without ever having to interact with you
so here's what i'm saying there's a
couple of different things
here's what i don't want you to do
if there's nothing like you're not going
to have
you're not going to talk to people
you're not going to chase down all
brothers and sisters you're not going to
call your mom you're not going to do
these things so waiting two months
to wrap this up
is going to make you and your brand new
baby nuts
not really your brand new baby i kind of
just do that in for a fact but it's
going to make you and your husband
bonkers
yeah i'd much rather you see you just go
meet this fine i'm going to go get my
test today
and dude you've got 48 hours you're my
dad and you're about to be a grandfather
you got 48 hours
like i would approach it that way
and i'm taking control of this
here if you hear nothing else hear this
you don't like conflict
and conflict has found you
okay great and so i i would in fact if
i'm you i'm i'm retracting what i said
earlier i'd be on the phone with
everybody i would schedule that dna test
in a staggered thing either at a police
department in a non-emergency police
department or at a local shop i'd go
ahead and do mine and be gone and then
tell him he's got 48 hours to come do it
there and i would call my mom i'd call
everybody i would turn all the lights on
and be like so some guy's coming out is
this right because the blood test is
already on the way mom what do you got
to tell me i would do it like that
and if she says you're crazy nothing
this never happened like cool well the
test is going to find out because this
is bananas
and dude
call me back if you come to find out
that your dad was really alive all this
time
because now you're in a whole other
adventure right
yeah that's kind of what also is
stressing me out too i think maybe
that's the whole idea of oh i'm going to
wait these couple months because i just
don't know how to deal with it um
because and then the other crazier part
i don't know if i mentioned this but
he's
been in this in a city where
you know like i was living my whole
childhood he was there that's what he
told my husband so there's lots of
there's lots of stories about
um
strange arrangements early on someone
might have struggled with alcohol drug
addiction somebody might have struggled
with
um any number of things
and there's a handshake agreement
between a mom and a dad saying
i'll step out of their life
but they watch their life from afar i've
seen some really heartbreaking stories
where
moms or dads out of the picture who have
been told hey your mom and dad died have
these real elaborate like uh photo
albums of school clippings and things
like that that they just watched their
kid grow up they just weren't in their
life
and so that i mean that didn't surprise
me at all not even a little bit but
they're me who knows what the story was
26 years ago who knows what the story
was right
um and whatever story you get will
probably mostly the truth-ish
right
um
maybe so i don't know so before we
before i let you go
i don't know what to root for here
whether i don't know either desperately
want your dad to be alive and you to
have the other 75 years of your life
with him
or or he won't be 70
50 more years with him and you all
figured that out
or and find out your mom lied to you
just stole from you or
um
that i want this thing to be put to bed
put to rest
which one do you want
it's hard to say for me too i think
in an ideal world i could have both of
those relationships but something tells
me
um
it's going to be
either
one you know my mom or my dad or none of
them
because these are
i know how my mother is very um
extreme so gotcha it would take a while
to rebuild yeah so here's a beautiful
moment you're about to have is this your
first baby
yes girl or boy
a boy all right so you're about to and i
would have said all right if it was a
girl too i'm just just trying to be
supportive um
you and your husband and now your new
son
this family is y'alls
so nobody else gets a vote
not your mom not your this person coming
out of the woodwork nobody you all too
you all decide who else gets to speak
into your life
and what i'd love for you and your
husband to do before you get the blood
test before you start making the calls
which i hope you do today i hope you
start today and you're like you know
what
forget everybody this is mine right i
hope that's your attitude
but i want you and your husband to come
up with the boundaries
talk to mom once a day
i will answer mom's text once a day
regardless of what happens
i will
invite this man to dinner one time
until we and then i will then regroup
from there i want y'all to set some
boundaries
so that when whatever happens happens
you don't immediately get dragged
underwater
that you're like whoa mom lied to me for
25 years all right we've already etched
in stone here i'm only going to talk to
her once a day so i'm going to text her
and say mom i got the paternity test
back this man is my father
this is very hard for me right now i
will be in touch
and then i'm not answering the phone
after that i'm not answering text
messages because i am in control these
are my boundaries these are me and my
husband's boundaries hear what i'm
saying
for 26 years claire
you've lived under this thumb this thumb
and today it comes off yeah hear what
i'm saying
yes i'm ready for that today you become
freaking claire and the thumb comes off
ready right let's go let's go say thank
you
yes
today is the day
that claire says no this is mine this is
my life
it's my life cue bon jovi right now
which would have been epic you missed
that one then that's a cool though
we cube on jovi it's your life it's time
to stand up boundaries for you
hey let me know because i want to know
how this one ends we'll be right back
[Music]
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's go to robert in green
bay what's up robert
hi dr dolony it's a pleasure talking to
you it's a pleasure to talk to you man
what's up dude how are you doing
good um so my question is um how do i go
about parting ways with uh two of my
existing friends
um a little back stories i'm 21 years
old
i've been friends with one individual
since high school and the other for
about two years and they are boyfriend
and girlfriend and i just feel that i
have complete opposite goals and they do
um
they are more of the type of people that
like to hit up every happy hour every
day
uh they like to go on vacations while
we're young and
um
and then like buying vehicles that are
ten to twenty thousand dollars more than
than what they make a year and i just
feel like that there's a lot of a lot of
negativity and a lot of issues in in
their life not saying that that's not
normal but i also don't want that to
affect me in my life and i'm just more
the type of person that
likes to stay in save money
work on physical and mental health and
just focus on my part-time job which
in the end can help me get a full-time
job faster and i'm just wondering how do
i go about talking to them about
um like my issues and how i feel towards
them without sounding rude or like
sounding better than them even though
that's not the issue at all
even though i yeah i am i am better than
that
that would have been way cooler if
that's how you did into that sentence
um
so
i'll answer it this way
when i graduated college are you about
to graduate now
i graduated last year okay it was i went
to a tech school okay um and so are you
in some sort of internship or
apprenticeship
um i was in an internship last year but
that just ended um recently so now i'm
just working working a part-time job
which gives you a little bit of a
stepping stone towards
getting
to the ultimate goal of full-time job in
this field
is this something you have to do or now
that you've you're credentialed and
qualified you can't just go get a
full-time job
uh i applied the i it's i'm in the fire
service so it's like they only hire
really once a year because they have to
go through
you know budgets and things like that
and like the academy and things like
that so yeah okay all right
um so
here's what i'd say
when i graduated college um
i
probably my sophomore year in college
several of my buddies moved out of the
residence hall i moved to one place they
moved to another
and i'm talking about my buddies todd
and john
and todd and john
went to different places we ended up
with like different social lives and i'd
see them out every once in a while and
it was cool i missed like hanging out in
the residence hall with them and being
silly and we'd do certain things
together we'd put on boxing gloves and
beat each other up once a year like
stuff like that but just dumb stuff
but by and large they had separate lives
we just kind of faded out
and then i graduated and i ended up
moving back in with them for a few
months and they came through in a way
for me that
forever altered my life and that's it
for a different story but
then i moved and i was gone for a few
years
and then i came back to visit and i had
an interaction with todd and i was like
dude what a what happened to you man
just kind of turned into a dork and he
was like dude you kind of turned into a
dork and yeah we just kind of moved on
well then fast forward i moved back to
that same city
um a year or two later
and
then slowly but surely we you know now
i'm 23 24 we started hanging out every
monday night
and then john joined us and then another
guy joined us and
fast forward 20 years later
that person if i got fired today if my
wife passed away he'd be my first phone
call
yeah john would be my second so here's
what i'm telling you
two things that are important number one
you're in a season when everyone starts
shaking the snow globe
right i'm trying stuff out i'm thinking
you are trying out what does laser focus
in workout and nutrition and reading all
of the cool books and listening to all
the cool podcasts and going to bed
you're trying that out
and they're trying out let's live our
you know yolo best life in our 20s and
here's the the
un uncomfortable truth
both of y'all are going to have scars
when it's over
i spent my 20s in grad school like a
nerd and i ended up with a couple of
doctorates i did a lot of cool stuff
but i missed all the fun nights like
just being stupid and 23 because i was
so crazy working
and then my buddies who were like yeah
bro
and they were like just getting their
club
like dude they all still have the same
degree and they're kind of circling the
same jobs not todd and john those dudes
are crushing but here's what i'm telling
you
i i wouldn't write off lifelong friends
i would create some space
okay because my guess is you all have
more in common than you think
they're figuring out who they are you're
figuring out who you are and it sounds
like they need more of you in their life
and it sounds like to some degree you
need some of them in your life
like you probably could use to go out
and have some fun every once in a while
and they probably need to not make
stupid purchasing you hear what i'm
saying
yeah yeah so do you feel like you have
to have and i hear this a lot from 21 22
23 year olds in a way that i never felt
this but times have changed clearly
do you feel like you have to have some
grand announcement or can you just
slowly fade out for a season
i feel like that i can that i can slowly
fade out i just didn't want them to
think something was wrong and obviously
if if they came up to me and approached
me and asked um like why haven't you
been coming around i mean i probably
would explain but i didn't know if i
should just kind of take a step back
from everything for a while and just let
them do their thing or if i should like
be like hey this is what's going on this
is what i'm gonna do like i'm gonna do
leaf right now when you do you
i i think i would leave out the udu part
i want this because here's what you're
kind of trying to do you're trying to
look for reasons why
you want to live the life you want to
live you hear what i'm saying so instead
of standing on two feet and saying i
really want to use my early 20s to get
way ahead financially i want to use my
early 20s to work like crazy on my
career i need my early 20s to
get ahead physically and create some
habits physically they're going to last
me the rest of my life spiritually and
mentally psychologically
like
you don't feel comfortable enough with
this track so you feel like you have to
say it's because i don't want to be like
that you don't need that part
you get what i'm saying okay so if they
say hey man where you been be like dude
i'm just trying i'm in a season of
trying to crush it right now
and i'm sorry i've been m.i.a but i'm
all about like trying to figure out my
job and my fitness and my mental health
and all that kind of stuff
and um dude that's on me i'm just going
you can leave it there and take full
ownership of your choices and decisions
and
you mentioned something important that
hang on to this okay you said i don't
want him to think something is wrong
but something is super wrong
right
yeah
you don't like them right now and that's
okay i still think you probably love him
or you wouldn't even care about having
this conversation and so
man there's season my wife doesn't like
me she still loves me she doesn't like
me i can be pretty annoying right you're
in shame with my buddies todd and john
i'd go we'd go hang out watch the fights
get into some philosophical social issue
debate i'd be so pissed i'd go home i
wouldn't sleep i'd be raged out and then
we're back together next friday laughing
and talking about other stuff right so
that's just what good friends do
i would just go about doing my life man
and if they reach out to you great like
hey look i think i am going to go out
tonight but i don't think it needs to be
some stand at the edge of the you know
the capitol steps announcement hear ye
hear you does that sound fair
yes it does how long have you been
friends with
them um
since high school with one of them and
then just the last two years with the
other okay
man this is heartbreaking to hear but
these kind of relationships will come
and go in your life and a few of them
will stick around forever
many of them won't or you'll see them in
a mall somewhere or on a ball field and
you're like oh hey man what's up like
that'll happen and that's cool
i would just uh hold them loosely man
hold them loosely and then you focus on
you right now and i will also tell you
this before i let you go
do not do this next season of your life
by your by yourself
cool
you have to have other people
whether that's getting together once a
week whether that is having coffee in
the mornings whether that's older than
you same age as you what i don't care
what it is
don't just crush life to the exclusion
of community because i've spent my
career working with 30 and 40 and 50
year olds who quote unquote made it
and they are completely and totally
alone
and all of your successes in vain if you
don't have people to live your life with
is that fair
yes that's awesome hey brother i'm
rooting for you um and congratulations
on making wise choices when it comes to
money and your physical fitness and
stuff like that that's fantastic don't
forget to smile and laugh a lot too
along the way we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they don't even think about it you are
worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back you box of cracker
jacks let's go to
giselle in new orleans is it gisele
yeah you said it right how are you dr
john yes i was about to say gazelle but
i said gizelle and i like it i get that
all the time beautiful beautiful name so
what's going on how can i help
hi um so
yeah i guess my question is sorry i'm a
little nervous too oh dude i'm super
nervous you've heard that i'm not very
good at this and giselle is a wonderful
name so i'm i'm out on the thin ice here
you're good
um yeah i guess my question is um
[Music]
i have really been struggling with um
people pleasing for
as long as i can remember i'm sorry i'm
choking up a little bit no it's okay
it's okay
tell me about it
yeah um
man it's just it's just hard to even
know um
who i am sometimes because i feel like
depending on who i'm talking to or
people in my life i'm just trying to be
um who they want me to be or
not not upset them or hurt them or be a
burden so
um
yeah it's just been a real struggle
with people pleasing and not really
knowing who i am
in the process because i'm trying to be
who everyone else wants me to be or not
hurt people or be a burden to them i
don't i don't know if that's making
sense oh big hey big time
and
like it breaks my heart who told you
this
who who modeled this for you that this
was the way you needed to go through
life
um
i guess for as long as i could remember
it never felt safe to be vulnerable or
share
how i felt was that mom or dad or both
or a brother or sister where did that
come from
um
[Applause]
i i hate to put it on my parents i would
i would say my mom if i'm being honest
yeah
and
yeah just it just sucks
um
i'm struggling in relationships with
friendships and
and i get all the time people saying
giselle you're way too nice you you
don't speak up you don't say what's on
your mind and i just feel paralyzed yeah
um
somewhere so i want to free you from
something okay
i bet you and i could sit down over a
cup of coffee and you could tell me some
stuff about your childhood that would
haunt me is that true
um not not from a traumatic uh like
abuse kind of thing but some things that
your mom said that are still firmly
planted in your soul
yeah
and
was your dad in the picture too
um yes and no like they had a great
marriage and their great parents i think
it just felt very emotionally absent
there so here's here's what i want you
to hear me say
trauma is acute and i know that you're
like whoa it's not trauma
when moms lodge
personality issues into you or when you
are responsible for making sure mom is
happy or not angry or not exhausted or
not tired or not stressed
that is a weight
that a child is not strong enough to
carry and
when there is another parent figure in
the home who doesn't reach over to help
that's trauma too
traumas both the things that were done
to you and the things that should have
happened that weren't that didn't happen
hear what i'm saying
yeah i i hear what you're saying and i
in no way want to just sit here and bash
on your parents i don't know their life
i don't know what's going on
but what i want you to do is this i want
you to draw the string from where did
where did my body learn
to to cycle down
because now that you're how old are you
now
uh 28 okay you're 28
and the way it comes out now the advice
you get the
pinterest and instagram scrolling that
we do now tells you
you just need to fill in the blank
and it turns into a character issue or a
moral issue or a strength like you're
weak or you're not strong enough why are
you not letting just standing up
and what i want you to hear me say is
your body's acting on your behalf
your body recognizes that when somebody
throws out a strongly worded sentence
and you object to it you better be quiet
because it's safe here in the silence
or when a guy starts putting you in a
situation that you're not comfortable
with
go along for the ride it's just better
for everybody
just don't say anything
or when your boss says something and
you're like what
well that's not even my fault would it
just it's gonna be fine just right am i
onto something
yeah i just
like i definitely agree it's either
paralysis or it feels like well if i
just
lie to avoid this conflict or
to tell the person what they want to
hear then i'll be okay that's right even
if it's not
the truth and so if you take your
like the alarms going off in your body
and sometimes we call those emotions or
feelings whatever you want to call
when you take those and you just squash
them
if you think about compressing them down
another word of compression is to
depress
right
yeah is to push down
and so many people walk through their
lives
with everything compressed into a tiny
nuclear reactor that just sits in their
soul and it eats them from the inside
out
absolutely
so if no one's ever told you this before
you are worth laughing at things you
think are funny
you're worth having your own opinions
especially when everyone disagrees with
you
you're probably really really smart
because you've got to watch a lot of
loud-mouthed idiots in your day without
trying to compete
you probably have a
i would say world-class probably
borderline superhero ability to read
people's energy because you've had to to
stay safe
yeah you know when a punch is coming you
know when a threat is on your way
and you also know like the matrix how to
get out of the way of that thing or how
to just take it and keep going
and i want you to know that those
qualities can also make you
an extraordinary leader
a powerful person who speaks when they
want to when they decide it's necessary
and that when they do speak everybody
listens
you can be in dating relationships and
romantic relationships where your needs
are met
all of them
and where you have permission to meet
other people's needs
you're worth all of that okay
how do you want to move forward
um
i guess that's why i'm calling too
because i just i feel like now i'm
either more aware of it or i've just
gotten to the point where i'm exhausted
and
i'm i'm ready to i'm just ready to make
changes and awesome
yeah okay so
two words that you've mentioned today
are giant red flags for me can i poke on
them for a minute
yeah okay
you are not
have never been
and will never be a burden
never say that word again
fair
fair
i'll say it again
you are not have not and will never be a
burden
you are my new sister and my new friend
and that word leaves your vocabulary you
may be uncomfortable you may be
surrounded by weirdos
you may be in a room of people who don't
like seinfeld you're the only one with a
sense of humor and clearly superior
intelligence
but you're never a burden
do you believe me right
i believe you
kids who grow up with moms who just
swipe
their phones all day and ignore them
kids who grow up with moms who yell and
scream a lot
or say oh honey don't wear that shirt we
don't look pretty in that like that kind
of stuff
kids who grow up with dads who don't
hold them tightly and say i love you i
love you i love you
the alternative is they feel like there
must be something wrong with me
because my dad won't even hug my dad
won't even tell me he loves me my dad
won't even fight for me my mom won't
even look at me my mom gets mad and she
ghosts me she turns silent on me
and i'm only eight what did i do that
was so bad that this adult who i'm
supposed to love won't even talk to me
right so all those things translate to
25 years down the road 20 years down the
road
this room would be better if i just
wasn't here
and that's not
true
okay
okay the second thing is the exhaustion
you feel is a almost 30 year old woman
whose body has been fighting and running
and freezing year after year after year
for way too long
your body's been on on
full tilt
for decades now
and this is the season when
you start taking one more drink and one
more drink
or you hook up with one more person
or you
eat one more this is me looking in the
mirror bag of candy or donut or whatever
or you get on a treadmill and you run
one more mile or you work 10 more hours
this week and then 10 more hours next
week at work this is when our bodies
start to say dude i can't keep doing
this and so we start looking for duct
tape to put over the alarms
am i on onto something
yeah or the new drug the new 21st
century drug is netflix i'm just gonna
go home and get under the covers
yeah right so
here's where we go from here number one
this is gonna be a cheesy answer and i
hope it doesn't sound like a ball of
cheese but i want you to hang on the
line i'm gonna send you a copy of
my new book it's called own your past
change your future it's like you just
threw this one to me on an underhand
softball pitch okay
it's gonna walk you through it
the path here is this
you have to own the stories and i know
you love your mom i know you love your
dad and you love your siblings and your
high school boyfriend whatever you got
to own those stories
only when you own them does your brain
go okay she now knows
where the bears are
and then you got to acknowledge reality
here's where i'm at i'm 28 years old i'm
beautiful i'm actually pretty dang smart
i'm kind
i think i'm funny and i've got a good
sense of humor and i do like power
rangers movies and i don't care what
people say about like whatever whatever
the thing is right
you gotta own reality
and then you have to be about the hard
stuff
which is i gotta grieve what i should
have had that i don't have
i have to
begin to work hard on changing my
actions and work hard on changing my
thoughts what does that look like in
reality
super hard yet super simple
it is when the moment you think oh i
just need to be quiet you say
inside your head nope i'm just gonna
speak out just because i'm practicing
and then you raise your hand or you just
speak out because all the other idiot
dudes in the room are speaking it like
no bro i don't like that you go nope i
actually do like that i like the colors
on that font i like the marketing angle
here
and as the only woman in this room i
think women would buy this
and then you inside you go the voices
will go what are you doing no
right
they already are okay just yeah just
practicing that and here's what i want
you to do i want you to feel that don't
run from it go right in the middle of it
and let your body know we're okay
and if these idiots fire me for speaking
up they suck and i don't want to work
here anyway
but they probably won't they i'm a
loudmouth idiot and i try to be
inclusive but i just get all fired
i love it when people in my who are on
my team
who normally are quiet speak up
because they're usually right
okay
and i want you to practice this and i
want you to feel it in your body the big
thing here is when your body takes off
on you when your heart starts beating
when you're when you start to shrink
back
have a next thing in line
nope
i'm not going to back up here
nope i don't want to kiss you i'm just
going to tell you that's not happening
tonight thank you though
don't worry i'll pay for my half of
dinner tonight whatever that looks like
for you mom nope i'm not coming home for
thanksgiving this year i'm gonna stay
with my friends
because i'm almost 30 and i can do
whatever i want to are you you see what
i'm saying
yeah i definitely see what you're saying
so
do you have a friend
do you have somebody in your life that
you can begin to discuss some of this
with
probably some of it for the first time
ever
yeah the second part
yeah so you've heard me say this on this
show a million times i'll say it more
time
grief demands a witness
you have to say some of these things out
loud
did you know my mom told me one time can
you believe my dad didn't
you have to say those things out loud
it's how we bring our mind back online
oh she here she acknowledges this okay
cool
bear threat averted now we will stop
responding as though everything's on
fire
and you're gonna have to train your body
over time to be less anxious and to be
less exhausted
and give it the
it needs
but if you will keep taking these tiny
little steps keep practicing towards
becoming the person that you're aiming
towards
i promise you you will become it you
know how i know cause i did
because my wife did because my friends
around me have
okay
okay so i'm down the road from you
i'm looking on the other side and i'm
telling you there's a light over there
if you'll work hard for the next couple
of years
and working hard just means practicing
this new way of being and you're gonna
fall
you're gonna i've been in meetings here
then i didn't speak up
and i drove home so pissed at myself
and i told somebody or two people and
then i got back in it the next day
you're gonna do that it's gonna be part
of your journey and then you're gonna
just find yourself
with a an ability to shoulder and carry
things that you never knew you had
because somebody took that from you and
you were very very young
so do you feel ready to rock and roll or
what
yeah
it's definitely scary um
yes so scary i'm ready and
you
are worth it
[Music]
you believe me
i do
you don't so i'm gonna say it again
you're worth it
you are not
will never be
have never been a burden
you my new friend gizelle
are worth it
you're worth it you're worth it you're
worth it you're worth it
and to everybody listening to this
you're worth it
we'll be right back
research has shown that the food you eat
directly impacts your mental and
physical health and that's why i'm a
maniac about putting good food into my
body and my family's body but we all
know that good food is super expensive
and when was the last time you went to a
butcher shop but my friends at
greensbury have solved it all greensbury
is a direct to consumer usda grade
organic meat provider right now they're
putting together a john doloni starter
pack filled with my favorite cuts how
crazy is that ribeye steaks ground beef
chicken breast pork chops bacon salmon
you got it go to
greensbury.com to get 10 off your
starter pack sent to your door today
all right we are back so
one of the things i talked about on the
show a lot
that just gives me hemorrhoids
is our obsession i don't really have
hemorrhoids by the way i'm all good
we should bat preparation h as a sponsor
by the way i talk about hemorrhoids a
lot on the show probably more than this
makes anyone comfortable but just put
that in the notes there
um
is
our obsession with tech
and before you click off be like
one of the things here's here's
my
what i want to say about technology
number one i love technology remember
that uh brings me so much joy i love me
some napoleon um
it's not that i hate technology i
actually love it
i love it
i love the fact that we're communicating
right now it's one way of course unless
you leave me some internet notes but
like it's one way but we're
communicating i love this microphone i
love this laptop i just carry around i
can watch every movie ever made on it
it's i love it i love being my family's
out of town all i've been able to call
them to facetime with i love all that
stuff
what i don't love is the existential
shift that we've undergone and this is
something i put uh i talked a little bit
about in the new book as one of the
stories that we've all just been handed
and we just started eating it without
even thinking about it
and here's the story the story is that
technology and innovation
can solve all of our problems
that whether it's personal nutritional
spiritual existential medical whatever
it is any problem you can think of
technology is gonna solve it save us
and
let's be completely clear technology has
given us a safer world
it's giving us a less hungry world
but it will never
be able to solve our deepest existential
spiritual connectivity needs
and yes
i'm going on the record there and they
will come up with alexa 9.0
and they'll come up all those things
that will really integrate into us i get
all that ai is
whoa
i've been in some tech rooms buying
closed doors what's coming with ai is
unfathomable it's really hard to wrap
your head around
it's still not going to fill the gap
and so now we find ourselves in this
interim space
with
a million devices meant to save time and
help us work less but we're busier than
ever
we're more connected to everybody
i've got people reaching out to me on
instagram from
a ton of other countries
right i'm watching what's going on
overseas in real time i'm just watching
videos of it happening i saw this is
going to be delayed by the time this
comes out but the president of ukraine
just spoke directly
to congress yesterday via
like zoom
that's amazing
it's incredible
we're super connected and we are
lonelier than ever before
lonelier at the cellular level
at the integrated community level right
with every app do we add to our life
there's a cost involved that amounts to
a greater disconnection from ourselves
everything we try to protect ourselves
from whether it's death whether it's um
doing our own laundry whatever it is
creates a gap
that takes us a little further off the
ground a little further off the ground
and at some point our feet begin to go
whoa whoa we're not tethered anymore
we're not telling we're not tethered and
our brain is going it's cool it's cool
it's cool we're floating it's cool and
all sudden we find ourselves 50 feet off
the ground and it's not safe
it's not safe
hard work
with a purpose
is healing that's a physiological fact
human touch that is safe and warm
is healing that's a fact
coming together as a group of people
is good for us for the planet for our
neighborhoods for everything in between
that is a fact
and this obsession we have with tech
dude i just james gave me this this
article here
the new survey shows their serious
appetite for ai powered dating apps and
virtual partners
a customer service platform surveyed a
thousand plus people and uncovered a
treasure trove of data
56 would like ai to offer
recommendations for in-app messages
meaning they want prompts on what should
i say next i don't know what to say next
which i don't know what to say and the
computer goes how about you say
wow you are pretty
would you like to kiss me on the head
to which i would be like all right sweet
um oh if anyone ever texts you and says
hey would you like to kiss me on the
forehead just just
ghost
block whatever you do on the internets
69 would let ai analyze their profile
and offer recommendations to make it
more attractive you know why because
you're not good enough
but you know what could make you good
enough
artificial intelligence
they'll give you some tips and pointers
on how to be more you so more people
will like you
people would end a relationship not as
many if ai recommended it
um
13 would share their dna to help find
the perfect partner
good folks
70 said they would change their mind
about sharing personal information if it
meant they would find the perfect match
you know what the perfect match is
waking up every day saying i'm going to
love this person with all i got
and they wake up and do the same
a perfect match is saying i'm sorry over
and over and over again for 50 years
until you both die
a perfect match is saying wow i screwed
that up
how can i do this better next time
or i spent all of my this for you
or i missed that concert for you or i'm
going all in for you or i'll do dishes
tonight i'll do bedtimes tonight and
i'll do them tomorrow night i'll do them
the next night
absolutely i'll figure out how to mow
the lawn it's gonna look like a drunken
idiot did it but i'm going for it
that's a perfect match
perfect matches and somebody just
floating up there on a star
technology innovation
they're not saviors from clouds
your neighbor is
you are
your spouses your friends are
your churches your community is
anything you guys want to add
kelly james james just showed up good to
see you buddy
i don't have anything to add but we're
going to bring in some alternate lyrics
of the day based on this discussion so
just get ready for that oh we are
i'll bring him in
oh did you find some all right
stand by america
james is uh call it an audible
and as easily the most conservative
person back there this ought to be good
[Laughter]
ah
[Applause]
so help me transition from my sed i
don't know how to get out of here i
think the lyrics speak for themselves
i've just kind of crashed and burned
these things this thing here's the thing
reconnect with real people
that's the path to healing reconnect
with yourself that's the path to healing
reconnect with your stories that's the
path to healing don't just sit at home
and wait for somebody some algorithm to
come in and save you
as we wrap up today's show
this is from james
his favorite song ever
off the napoleon dynamite soundtrack
this is kip's wedding song
and it goes like this
why do you love me
why do you love me always and forever
we met in a chat room now our love can
fully bloom
sure the world wide web is great but you
you make me salivate
yes i love technology
but not as much as you you see
but i still love technology
always and forever our love
james is like a flock of doves
flying up to heaven above always in
forever yes our love is truly great
always in forever why do you need me
always and forever download the app
and i just realized download the app is
something you just cut and pasted and
put on this word document not part of
the lyrics we'll see you next time right
here
coming up on the next episode yo
i am cleaning someone else's house
uh do you have the permission to be in
there he blindsided me
and told me that he doesn't love me
doesn't know if he ever did
you're worth more than all of this i'm a
new teacher at a public high school oh
no
okay go ahead
i feel like i'm the capri sun my husband
daughter and even my dog all have straws
there's times where i'm like laying in
bed at 2 30 am feeling like a capri sun
yeah your body isn't a wonderland your
body's a jungle gym it might be a
wonderland that's not for me to say
shipments of cds rose from 31 million
to
47 million suckers cds are coming back